Land und Brecht
[Musik]
schönen guten Morgen Richard guten
Morgen Markus schön deine Stimme zu
hören du hast wieder eine ja genau das
ist das eigentliche Wunder bis vor drei
Tagen hatte ich wirklich keine so
unfassbar war seltsam ja ich plötzlich
einfach weg ich hatte sonst nichts aber
es hatten sich Viren entschlossen sich
genau auf meine Stimmbänder zu setzen
und es war lustig aber versucht dich
mundtour zu machen oder
keine Verschwörungstheorien ich würde
sagen nein ich glaube es waren einfach
nur und ich bin auch nicht ganz sicher
ob es dann nur Bedauern darüber gab dass
ich mal nicht sprechen konnte
ich glaube der ein oder andere war ganz
froh darüber ist einfach mal eine ganz
neue Erfahrung für jemanden aus meinem
Gewerbe mal so lange die Klappe zu
halten ist schon ja was macht das mit
dem
also bist du bist du in der Zeit
nachdenklicher geworden weil du dich nur
mit dir selbst unterhalten konntest ja
ich hoffe ich habe meine innere Mitte
gesucht immer noch nicht so richtig
gefunden aber
er hat gemerkt wie was für ein wichtiges
Werkzeug die Stimme tatsächlich ist ne
es ist
interessant und das Ding ist typisch
Mann wenn man fängt dann natürlich
sofort an mit seiner schweren Krankheit
zu hadern sofort ja und meine erste
Frage an meinen HNO
Jörn der echt gute Arzt ist liebe Grüße
ich und warum ausgerechnet ich warum
muss mich das Treffen und und Jörn sagt
irgendwie völlig falsche Frage die
richtige Frage ist warum du nicht ja ja
und ehrlich gesagt steckt da sehr viele
Wahrheit drin in dieser in dieser
Republik weil das ist ja auch die Frage
die man sich stellt wenn sein wirklich
ernsthafter wischt ne warum ausgerechnet
ich aber wahrscheinlich ist es so
philosophisch hoch interessant die
falsche Frage warum du nicht ja genau
seitdem ist es ja so irgendwann kommt
immer mal jeder dran ja also es gibt
diesen schönen Satz von Marcel du schon
diesen Künstler irgendwie sterben immer
die anderen ja genau aber das sagen
natürlich die anderen über den eigenen
Tod den man irgendwann erleidet auch so
ist es ja so ähnlich wie bei Corona ja
wo ist auch immer nur eine Frage der
Zeit war wann es einen dann endlich doch
mal erwischt ja und ich sagen muss
bislang ist es ja immer noch an mir
vorbeigegangen an dir ja wirklich ich
habe den Verdacht dass ich es irgendwann
mal hatte ist aber schon viele Monate
her aber meine meine Tests waren damals
merkwürdigerweise immer negativ ich habe
aber weil du gerade über den Tod
sprichst ich habe dieser Tag ein
großartiges Interview mit mir angesehen
jetzt hat er mehrfach erzählt aber die
die Geschichte ist so gut der auf die
Frage ob er den Angst vorm Tod hätte
sagt nein das ist gar kein Problem weil
man merkt es nicht wenn man tot ist das
kriegst du nicht mit ja genau das ist
übrigens eine berühmte Weisheit von
Epikur ja ich weiß und er aber die
Pointe darauf ist so schön weil er sagt
dann weißt du das ist wie mit der
Blödheit das ist nur schmerzvoll für die
andere für die anderen das sind schöner
Vergleich der ist nicht von Epikur ich
wollte gerade sagen
genauische Weisheit auch als volksspruch
quasi weil Otto Reuter sozusagen ein
eine Rapper der 20er Jahre ja der hat in
diesem Lied in 50 Jahren ist alles
vorbei und das in diesem Satz gebracht
ja nur einmal im Jahr blüht der Mai und
eine 50 Jahren ist alles vorbei vom Tod
sich zu fürchten hat keinen Zweck man
erlebt ihn ja nicht wenn er kommt ist
man weg ja genau
ich ich habe so dass das tröstlichste
und irgendwie mit das beste
kenne ist von Henning man kennt der hat
immer auf die Frage der ist ja dann
schwer an krebserkrankt und dann auch
gestorben und hat auf die Frage ob sich
davor fürchtet gesagt weißt du wir
sollten uns nicht so viele Gedanken über
den Tod und das Sterben machen denn
eines ist ja klar es ist noch nie einer
lebend aus der Sache herausgekommen das
ist wahr aber das sagt sich natürlich so
einfach ich also diese ich fand diese
Zäsur und das wirklich ne das war jetzt
eine Kleinigkeit aber es zeigt dir
natürlich trotzdem dass du verletzlich
bist das plötzlich irgendetwas kommen
kann manchmal ist es nur einen harmloses
Virus auf dem Stimmband aber manchmal
ist es dann eben mehr und ich habe das
auch auf dem Umfeld so erlebt wenn so
ein Anschlag dann kommt der Moment ist
hart aber ich war immer immer und das
ist sozusagen das das die gute Botschaft
die gute Nachricht ich habe immer
gesehen wie unglaublich stark Menschen
dann im Angesicht des Todes wurden also
wie sehr die über sich hinauswachsen und
wie sie wie sie sich nicht in
Selbstmitleid ergehen sondern wie sie
mit einer unglaublichen Kraft das dann
an dem was da ist ist tatsächlich für
die Umgebung häufig schmerzvoll als für
die dies betrifft ja also wo du sagst
mit Kraft in den Tod gehen schade dass
letzte Woche ausgefallen war weil da
habe ich auch gerade über einen Tod
nachgedacht über den Tod von Fred
fussbroich ja und das finde irgendwie
nahe gegangen naja Fan ist vielleicht
merkwürdiger Ausdruck aber ich würde
sagen es gibt so Dinge der akademischen
Philosophie die lernt man an der Uni und
es gibt so Dinge der praktischen
Philosophie die habe ich von euch
gelernt
werden ja das war eine Fernsehserie die
von Anfang der 90er bis Anfang der
Nullerjahre im Fernsehen lief und die
eine ganz normale Familie aus Köln
Mülheim Buchheim zeigte er war
Mitarbeiter sie arbeitete im Büro sie
lebt auch noch und er hat noch einen
Sohn und ja dann kam die Kamera und
begleitete die in ihrem täglichen Leben
also das was sagen wir mal später die
Geissens waren oder die Geistes hatten
hatten genau den Kardashians hatten die
fußbräuchten Niveau ja also ja weil ja
weil die hatten würde und Haltung und
Fred liebte es über das Leben zu
philosophieren er macht auch andere
lustige Sachen also werd von meinem
Freund Teppich verlegt und da waren
Luftlöcher unter dem Teppich und dann
hat er sich in seiner Ballonseide in der
sich ja gern gewandelt hat ja immer auf
dem Teppich hin und her gerollt um die
Luftlöcher dann sozusagen der Haus zu
kriegen also ein unvorstellbares Bild
aber ansonsten am liebsten sah es ja
eigentlich auf dem Sofa guckte Fernsehen
und philosophierte oder in Mallorca
Urlaub am Strand wenn also über den
Spanier philosophiert ja der Spanier an
sich ist ja klein ja so 1,60 ja das
kommt von dem
ja da war der völlig überzeugt worden
also viel Ernährung in Spanien deswegen
haben die sich auch nicht so Spanisch
ernährt wenn die da in Mallorca waren
nein aber der hatte eine eine
Souveränität und Gelassenheit die die
mir irgendwo imponiert hatte also ich
würde es mal so sagen Fred fußbroich
hatte als ich das guckte ich war ja da
mit der Ende 20 ja der hatte alles das
was mir fehlte nämlich
coolerinität
Gelassenheit ja genau er war sich in
seinem Modegeschmack auch wenn er nicht
meinem entsprach unglaublich sicher ist
das große während ich alles mögliche
noch ausprobierte also der hatte eine
Ruhe und Gelassenheit in sich also da
muss ich schon jetzt 57 werden um auch
nur ganz entfernt an Fred fussbroich
ranzukommen
Richard ich würde heute gerne mit dir
und auch wenn es seltsam anmutet
vielleicht ja wenn zwei Mittelalter
Männer sagen wir Best Ager über Frauen
sprechen aber es ist nun mal die
Situation und ich würde es wahnsinnig
gerne zum Thema machen die
frauen-proteste im Iran was passiert da
gerade im Iran und ich einfach nur damit
du da mal reinkommst ja ich wir haben in
der Sendung auch häufiger schon über
Massa Mini gesprochen aber was ist da
wirklich passiert und es gibt
mittlerweile eine ziemlich präzise
Rekonstruktion davon wie das alles
beginnt ich weiß nicht ob du das so im
Detail kennst ich trage es dir mal kurz
vor es ist der frühe Abend des 13
September und Master Amini 22 Jahre alt
tritt
in einer Jeans aus der U-Bahn in Teheran
trägt einen langen Mantel unter den
headjab so erzählt es die Mutter später
dann Journalisten sie will Verwandte
besuchen Klamotten kaufen für das
unisemester das bald beginnt ein
normaler Einkauf Bummel bis passiert was
heute nicht nur den Iran bewegt sondern
die ganze Welt die Sittenpolizei wird
auf diese junge Frau aufmerksam zehren
sie in den Wagen so schildert es später
jüngerer Bruder die Beamten drehen ihm
weil er helfen will den Arm auf den
Rücken oder muss mit ansehen wie seine
Schwester abtransportiert wird weil die
Kleidung diesen Leuten diesen
Sittenwächter nicht gefällt als
unislamisch gilt wenige Stunden später
das weiß man mittlerweile fällt Amine
ins Koma drei Tage später stirbt sie auf
einem Foto
mittlerweile weltberühmt
ikonographisches Foto im Krankenhaus ist
zu sehen wie Blut an ihrem rechten Ohr
klebt das Regime behauptet sie ist
anorganversagen gestorben als Folge
einer angeblichen Vorerkrankung und so
weiter aber es gibt Videos es gibt
Beweismaterial es zeigt wie eine junge
Frau durch eine Polizeistation schwankt
sich an einem Stuhl festhält dann
zusammenbricht Hacker liegt ein Bilder
einer Computertomographie der zeigt eine
Schädelfraktur und ihre Familie erzählt
sie hat Verletzungen in den Beinen
gehabt geschwollenes Gesicht und
deswegen ist für die meisten Iranerinnen
und Iraner mittlerweile klar was
passiert ist die Sittenpolizei hat sie
umgebracht das ist der Auslöser einer
Revolte die mittlerweile seit mehr als
40 Tagen geht und die das Zeug hat eine
echte Kraft und echte Wucht zu entfalten
hast du dich mal mit dem Iran
beschäftigt intensiver ja also als
erstes muss ich vorausschicken dass ich
neben Iran gewesen bin ja Iran ich auch
nicht war immer auf der Liste der Länder
wo ich ganz ganz unbedingt hin wollte
und der Hauptgrund dafür waren all die
Iraner die ich kennengelernt habe
und das sind relativ viele gewesen und
sind es bis heute und es ist einfach
interessant dass ich immer wenn ich
Menschen aus dem Iran kennengelernt habe
natürlich ist das auch manchmal ein
Zufall habe ich unglaublich freundliche
kultivierte ja lebensfreundliche
Menschen kennengelernt Menschen die gut
zuhören konnten Menschen die viel zu
sagen hatten
sehr häufig bei Iranern auch so eine so
eine philosophische Nachdenklichkeit
also ist auch ein Land mit einer sehr
hohen stehenden philosophischen Kultur
einer uralten Kultur immer ein Großreich
gewesen über den größten Teil der
Geschichte hinweg
und also eine unglaublich beeindruckende
Kulturnation und dann habe ich immer
diesen großen Widerspruch zwischen
diesem von einer religiösen 100
regierten die knebelten geknechteten
Land
wo sich also seit 44 Jahren die Mutter
ist an der Macht halten und dieser
dieser aufgeklärten
sensiblen kultivierten Bevölkerung und
das sind so zwei Dinge die man ja mit
dem gesunden Menschen verstanden nicht
zusammen in die gleiche gehirnkammer
sortieren kriegt genau es ist wahr
was interessantes ist und deswegen sagte
ich gar nicht so ein bisschen ironisch
sind ein bisschen seltsam wenn zwei
Männer über dieses Thema reden weil es
vor allen Dingen die Frauen sind die
diesen protestreiben mittlerweile das
weiß ich auch aus Gesprächen mit goldene
atai zum Beispiel unserer
Korrespondentin die sich sehr sehr
intensiv mit dem Thema beschäftigt
geht es auch um den Basar die die
Händler im Basar sind ganz ganz wichtig
sind ganz wichtiger Seismograf ja also
wenn die sozusagen plötzlich die Seiten
wechseln dann hat das Regime ein echtes
Problem aber es sind vor allen Dingen
Frauen und es sind unglaubliche Bilder
entstanden ich weiß nicht ob du das
verfolgst ich verfolgt das sehr sehr
intensiv ist auch interessant welche
Rolle soziale Medien bei dem Thema
spielen das ist das ist neu dass ein
also vergleichsweise neu aber das eine
eine Plattform eine amerikanische
Plattform dabei eine so zentrale Rolle
spielt das ist Instagram in dem Fall
alles andere ist quasi verboten seit
langer langer Zeit
aber Instagram nicht und wenn man mal
der Frage nachgeht warum ist das
eigentlich so dann ist es sehr
interessant weil es ähnlich ist wie mit
YouTube in Russland mich dieser Tage
natürlich auch viel mit mit Russland
beschäftigt und der Protest in in
Russland funktioniert vor allen Dingen
über Youtube ja wenn wenn die Russen
wissen wollen was wirklich in dem Land
passiert dann ist es YouTube und man
fragt sich warum schaltet das russische
Regime YouTube nicht ab und warum
schaltet das iranische Regime insgesamt
ich habe mich mit ihm mit rigovski dem
dem dem diesen Bestsellerautor den du
auch kennst Glückwunsch auf der
Buchmesse kennengelernt habe wirklich ja
jetzt gerade jetzt gerade es ist ein
super Typ ne Dimitri dukowski ist ein
Science-Fiction Autor Metro 33 mega Buch
ja es ist interessant dass jemand der
sich seines Lebens nicht mehr sicher
sein kann ja der also von der russischen
Geheimpolizei gesucht wird
dass der sich gleichzeitig so
Verschmitztheit so variarität und
ausgestrahlte Entspanntheit ja gesichert
hat also das war sehr beeindruckend über
über den und dieses russische
Lebensgefühl sollten wir auch mal
sprechen aber dukowski hat etwas
Interessantes erzählt bei uns in der
Sendung der sagte YouTube wird deswegen
nicht abgeschaltet weil 80 Millionen
Russen von ungefähr 130 grob nutzen
Youtube ungefähr 10 Millionen davon 10
bis 15 nutzen es politisch für den
ganzen Rest ist es entertainment
und ein Regime das sozusagen für so viel
emotionale Dunkelheit und Kälte und und
Freudlosigkeit sorgt ja wie es Putin und
seine seine Schergen dort machen die
können sich schlicht und ergreifen nicht
leisten den Leuten in schwarz genau
diesen Spaß wegzunehmen im Iran schalte
Youtube das was früher die
Fernsehunterhaltung waren genau und und
weil die russischen Medien das russische
Fernsehen so ist wie es ist ja geht man
dann eben auf Youtube im Iran scheint es
etwas anderes Motiv zu sein mit
Sicherheit auch Entertainment logisch
bei Instagram aber vor allen Dingen ist
Instagram dort ein extrem wichtige
Plattform geworden für den kleinen
Handel der Leute so untereinander ja
haben sich Dinge zu verkaufen anzubieten
ja so so so sehr sehr orientalischer
Zugang muss man sozusagen und deswegen
können die sich nicht leisten Instagram
einfach abzuschalten und haben
offenkundig völlig unterschätzt welche
sprenkraft diese Plattform die
eigentlich nur dem dem Entertainment dem
Zeitvertrieb und dem ein bisschen Handel
diente welche Sprengkraft diese
Plattform plötzlich entwickeln kann das
finde ich interessant ja ich irre aber
du hattest ja am Anfang sehr
optimistischen Satz gesagt du hast du
hast gesagt dass es jetzt endlich und
das hoffen ja ganz viele und das hoffen
wir ja auch zum Sturz des müller-reams
kommen könnte und die Frage die mich
natürlich am meisten beschäftigt ist
wird das so kommen oder nicht ich bin da
so ein kleines gebranntes Kind ich habe
mal mit einem Hamburger Geschäftsmann
vor ganz ganz langer Zeit schon gewettet
dass das Mullah Regime sich nicht mehr
lange wird halten können das war nach
dem Protesten von 2009
ich habe diese Wette krachend verloren
weil ich mir damals schon nicht
vorstellen könnte ich also wir haben
irgendwie so ein Zeitfenster von fünf
Jahren oder so ausgemacht ne wo ich
einfach damals gedacht habe also das
kann sich keine zwei drei Jahre mehr
halten in fünf Jahren ist das weg
und es hat sich als wahnsinnig stabil
erwiesen und es hat sich auch als
wahnsinnig stabil erwiesen 2019 und das
ist ja das verrückte dass man sich die
Frage stellen muss was braucht es damit
der Aufstand der Massen der Aufstand der
Frauen es sind ja nicht nur die Frauen
ist schließen sich ja Menschen aus allen
Schichten an ja was ja schon mal eine
gute Voraussetzungen Männer was auch
eine gute Voraussetzung ist aber was
braucht es damit tatsächlich ein ein
Umsturz passiert so wie das vor 44
Jahren war als Rumänien auf den Schal
gefolgt ist
und da gibt es leider und da muss man
ein ganz großes Leiter hinter setzen
immer noch viele Zweifel und für mich
besteht zwei Dinge wo ich immer denke
darüber denke mir vielleicht zu wenig
nach die der Grund sein könnten warum es
nicht klappt ja die muss man kennen
meine ich ich meine vielleicht gibt es
ja noch mehr und jemand der sich sein
Leben lang mit dem politischen Iran
beschäftigt hat der weiß das auch besser
aber das eine ist das System und zwar
das reine politisch formale System es
gibt ja ein obersten Revolutionsführer
der eine quasi autokratische macht in
dem Land hat das kann man hey ja und der
ist seit 33 Jahren an einer Macht der
comedianfolger
und der ist ja nicht vom Volk gewählt
und das Interessante ist wenn man den
Präsidenten stürzt ja wie der jetzt ja
auch erst seit kurzer Zeit an der Macht
ist und der irgendein radikaler
Hardliner ist ne dass dann dann hätte
man ja noch nichts verändert
man müsste ja quasi den
Revolutionsführer stürzen diesen
83-Jährigen so wie macht man denn das
also wie wie wie stürzt man den ja
jemand der nicht gewählt ist den kann
man auch nicht durch das Ausrufen von
Neuwahlen oder das Erzwingen von
Neuwahlen stürzen
das ist so der Unterschied weißt du zu
Weißrussland wo man gesagt hat im Grunde
hat da jemand die Wahl gefälscht und so
weiter da müsste man nur mal eine
richtige Wahl durchführen und dann wäre
Lukaschenko Weg das geht im Iran nicht
auch normal an der sich viele Leute
beteiligen an der letzten Wahl haben
sich ja nicht mal die Hälfte aller
Iraner überhaupt beteiligt auch aus
Protest nicht ja weil der am Ende hat
der Präsident ja auch gar nicht viel zu
sagen
letztlich ist also sozusagen immer eine
Stütze des Systems egal wer da an die
Macht kommt ob das jetzt ein Reformer
ist oder ob das eine Hardliner ist wie
jetzt und das macht die Sache richtig
schwierig also wie ganz konkret das ist
die erste Punkt mit dem zweiten reden
wir noch aber wie müsste das denn ganz
konkret aussehen also wie stürzt man
eine family ja
das kann ich dem einzelnen natürlich
nicht sagen ich habe noch nie eine
Revolution angeführt und zum
Revolutionsführer eigentlich mich auch
nicht aber was ich woran ich zutiefst
glaube richard ist die Macht und die
Kraft von Bildern und Medien und da
entstehen gerade ikonographische Sachen
und wenn wenn wenn man sich das mal
anschaut also die die die
Digitalisierung die Technologie die wir
haben die dafür sorgt dass es ja diese
Gleichzeitigkeit gibt nur das ist ja das
eigentlich Spannende am Netz ist ja in
Wahrheit genau das die sozusagen die
neue unter Anführungszeichen Art
Informationen zu verbreiten
in Echtzeit die Gleichzeitigkeit die
macht ja was also in dem Moment wo etwas
passiert gibt es die Möglichkeit dass
jeder der es möchte auf dem gesamten
Planeten kann etwas sehen und wenn du
dir zum Beispiel dieser dieses Bild
anguckst wie hast du das gesehen von
Sahel dieser Feministin aus Rast im
Nordiran seine junge Frau die von
Schrotkugeln im Rücken getroffen worden
wenn du das siehst diesen von
Schrotkugeln zersiebten Rücken ja dann
ahnst du welche Kraft das haben kann
dass das kann für ein solches Regime
können sind solche Fotos absolut tödlich
und gefährlich und können die am Ende
ins Wanken bringen wenn man dann die
Geschichte dazu hört dass die sich aus
Angst vor vor den Schergen lässt sie
sich dann zu Hause einfach von Freunden
behandeln um danach wieder auf die
Straße zu gehen das ist Wahnsinn dann
gibt es ich würde übrigens dazu sagen
die Kraft der Bilder ja ist nichts Neues
also wenn du überlegt was den
Vietnamkrieg kippen lassen dann sind es
unter anderem das weltberühmte Foto von
Kim Puck diese Mädchen dass da nackt
nach einem napalmangriff oder was das
war über die Straße läuft oder diese
andere dieses Bild wie in diesem
südvietnamesischen
Schergen damit der Glatze der da vor der
vor den vor den Augen so einen jungen
Mann erschießt ja also vor den Augen all
der anderen wurmstehenden also diese
Bilder diese ikonographischen Bilder Abo
Greif ja man könnte jetzt zu eigentlich
zu jedem großen Krieg oder Revolution
die ikonographischen Bilder aufzählen
und dass diese Bilder jetzt diese Macht
haben ja und das das ist alles das hat
eine Wucht und das hat eine Kraft aber
das ganze muss und das hat diesen
Vorteil eben das erfasst zunehmend die
Breite der Bevölkerung die aus sehr
unterschiedlichen Gründen unzufrieden
ist Iran hat eine wahnsinnige Inflation
also die die Kaufkraft der
Kaufkraftverlust der ist enorm die
Menschen sind arm geworden in den
letzten zehn Jahren immer ärmer ja es
gibt Gründe das ganz vielen Gründen also
die die einen die die dann die
Minderheiten die Kurden ja mit ihrem ihr
eigenes Interesse daran haben andere
religiöse Minderheiten die Sunniten die
still gehalten haben und der
schiitenherrschaft ja also es gibt sehr
sehr viel Potenzial aber dieses
Potenzial muss ja irgendeine eine
organisiertere Form annehmen aber
da hast du Recht aber die die Frage
sozusagen woher Sabine Rückert hat in
der Zeit ein ganz tolles Stück
geschrieben über die Frage woher kommt
der Mut und diese ist im Bild benutzt
sozusagen dieses dieses biblische Motiv
also David gegen Goliath die die diese
Erzählung die an so vielen Ecken
eigentlich immer wieder funktioniert hat
und die die Menschen wirklich fasziniert
also in modern übersetzt da wir gegen
Goliath Alex seener valny oder Greta
oder viele viele Ukraine gegen Russland
das ist dieses Ding und was halt so
faszinierend ist wie wenn man den
Menschen hören nichts lieber als die
Geschichten anderer Menschen und die
Geschichten anderer Menschen faszinieren
Menschen das ist das woran auch ich
immer wirklich zutiefst glaube es ist
völlig egal ob der der eine gute
Geschichte erzählt berühmt ist oder
Mittel berühmt ist oder ein bisschen
berühmt ist oder gar nicht berühmt ist
Menschen sind fasziniert von guten
Geschichten anderer Menschen
und das Internet und die digitale
Technologie sorgen dafür dass natürlich
diese Erzählungen
millionenfach verbreitet werden hast du
mitgekriegt die die diese diese
Kletterin die bei den Asien
Meisterschaften und Soul ohne Kopftuch
angetreten ist Wahnsinn du ich Du siehst
diese Bilder wie dieser Zopf hin und her
schwingt ja und sie ist an diesem Seil
gesichert ja und und steht dann da auf
und so wird dann hinterher und und da
merkst du wie so ein Regime an an
Grenzen kommt ne die ist ja hinterher
ist sie unter einem Vorwand das erinnert
alles fatal an kashoggi der
Araber der in Saudi der in der Botschaft
in Istanbul dann in Stücke gesägt worden
ist ja
die ist ebenfalls unter einem Vorwand in
die iranische Botschaft in dem Fall
gelockt worden Pass Handy alles
eingezogen und dann taucht wenige Tage
später plötzlich auf ihrem Instagram
Profil ein neuer auf ja das
heruntergerutscht wäre ja wo sie sich wo
sie sich entschuldigt wo sie um
Verzeihung bittet für die Sorgen die sie
bereitet hat und sie sei also nicht
absichtlich ohne Kopftuch geklettert und
so weiter und sich entschuldigt für die
Aufregung aber ich sage dir diese
Geschichte wo jeder sofort versteht wie
es zu diesem Post gekommen ist das fällt
den sowas von auf die Füße das
funktioniert nicht klar und das und das
ist die Kraft des Netzes und das ist die
Kraft dieser dieser neuen Art
Information zu verbreiten wir kommen ja
jetzt während des Gesprächs in so zwei
unterschiedliche Rollen also du sagst
gerade und das ist ja auch nur eine
Rolle weil wir ich wünsche mir ja genau
wie Du ja die schnellstmögliche Ende des
molaregimes und die Befreiung des
iranischen Volkes ja von dieser
kleptokratischen Kaste die dieses Land
im Schwitzkasten hält und den vielen
anderen mehr genau und die Frage ist auf
der einen Seite hast du die Macht der
Bilder du hast die die Breite über die
wir gerade gesprochen haben Bevölkerung
dass die Empörung die Entrüstung dieses
endgültige Gefühl von jetzt reicht es
aber wirklich was ja auch eine große
Kraft entfaltet und auch die in dieser
Mut vieler vieler junger Mädchen ja und
und junger Frauen zu sagen nee und die
die Graffities die gesprüht werden und
die Symbole die die überall im Land sind
und die immer wieder neu
aufschwall in den Unruhen und auf der
anderen Seite um eine erfolgreiche
Revolution zu machen das Beste was einem
passieren kann ist wenn man das Militär
auf seiner Seite hat
und hier ist das ganz große Probleme
Iran hat eine der größten Armeen der
Welt über 400.000 Soldaten und zu denen
kommen 200.000 sogenannte
revolutionskarten die Passe daran die
sind eingeschworen auf den raminai und
was die Sache besonders subtil macht da
gibt es noch 600.000 zumeist junge
Männer ja die man sieht Ski das sind die
Freiwilligen meditionäre dieser
revolutionsgarten das heißt also wir
haben insgesamt hier einen militärisches
Potenzial von 1,2 Millionen Menschen das
ist unvorstellbar viel ja und das
interessante an diesen revolutionsgarten
ist dass sie eine Art Start im Staate
bilden ungefähr ein Drittel der gesamten
iranischen Wirtschaft wird von diesen
revolutionsgarten und ihren Helfern und
Helfers Helfern die davon profitieren ne
junge Männer ohne Perspektive die da
aufgenommen werden und dadurch Karriere
machen können oder die gesicherte
existenzfristen können
die werden eben im Rahmen dieses
militärisch auf der einen Seite und auf
der anderen wirtschaftlichen komplexes
untergebracht und das ist eine irrsinnig
starke Macht in diesem Land und die sind
alle auf diesen kriminell eingeschworen
und profitieren von diesem System das
ist der einzige Grund warum sie an
seiner Seite sind weil sie natürlich
aber die profitieren wirtschaftlich von
diesem System vom Ansehen her von diesem
System und deswegen ist leider ja nicht
zu erwarten dass da jetzt ein Knick
kommt oder ein Bruch kommt oder nur dann
riss auf glaubst du das er glauben tue
ich gar nichts ich habe auch keine
Ahnung davon das war eine Befürchtung
also die Frage ich kann es auch als
Frage formulieren was müsste passieren
ja damit sozusagen die Profiteure dieses
Systems
für sich von sich aus von Family und von
dem System abwenden das wäre der
entscheidende Schritt wenn der passieren
würde dann wäre die Revolution da
aber es sind ja diejenigen die davon
profitieren dass die Dinge so sind wie
sie jetzt sind und die jetzt wenn es
einen eine Veränderung gäbe noch mal was
ich vorhin gesagt habe die Veränderung
würde ich ja nicht bedeuten da wird ein
Präsident
ausgewählt und der macht jetzt Reform
sondern die Veränderung müsste sein dass
diese ganze Systemarchitektur wieder
Iran funktioniert also dieses ganze
System ja mit den Revolutionären Garden
mit dem Revolutionsführer mit dem
Wächter Rad und so weiter das müsste
hier alles abgeschafft werden und da
gäbe es wahrscheinlich zu viele Leute
die zu sehr mit dem alten Regime
kooperiert haben davon profitiert haben
die das nicht wollen und für die
Situation sich verschlechtern würde und
da müsste eigentlich der Keil rein und
wenn das gelänge dann wäre die
Revolution wahrscheinlich gehen dann
hätte ich jetzt einen Vorschlag erinnert
ab dem Vorschlag wie wäre es wenn wir es
als Deutschland jetzt lass uns mal bei
uns sprechen wenn wir es zum Beispiel
mal so machen würden wie die Kanadier
was
ein ganz andere Liga ist als das was wir
machen ich weiß nicht wie du das
beobachtest aber
die Art wie wir uns als Land zu diesem
Protesten Verhalten finde ich Glinde
gesagt sondern mal über überschaubar in
Ordnung die die Kanadier haben genau
diese Leute diese ganzen
revolutionskernen die haben die einfach
alle alle kompletto offene banneliste
gesetzt alle ja das heißt die die die
die die die die haben Einreiseverbot die
können doch wir werden jetzt behandelt
wie russische so und das ist doch genau
richtig so und da reden wir über viele
viele Menschen was haben wir gemacht wir
haben die EU ne hat wegen dieser
Proteste Sanktionen erlassen gegen 11
Leute und vier Organisationen Kanada hat
10.000 Menschen sanktioniert die bei den
iranischen und Sicherheitskräften
Arbeiten ich finde das ehrlich gesagt
erbärmlich ich kann ihn ich kann ihn
noch was geben Symbolpolitik ja ein ein
was ich lese dir mal einen schönen Satz
vor es bestürzt mich dass bei den
Protesten im Iran friedlich
demonstrierende Menschen ums Leben
kommen wir verurteilen die
unverhältnismäßige Gewalt der
Sicherheitskräfte und stehen den
Menschen im Iran bei unsere
EU-Sanktionen sind wichtig wir prüfen
weitere Schritte Olaf Scholz so Annalena
baerbock wiederum die
gefeiert wird von vielen für angeblich
klare Aussprache hat lange lange
geschwiegen zu diesem Protesten ja
übrigens übrigens auch Herr nowimpur
also
gebürtiger Iraner so genau der der dann
als DJ sich betätigt auf ein Parteitag
das kann man alles machen das kann man
aber vielleicht zum falschen Zeit ich
genau und ich schätze auch mit Nuru pur
wirklich sehr aber ich glaube wenn man
mit ihm mal ehrlich darüber reden würde
das wird er wahrscheinlich heute auch so
sehen das fand ich wirklich schwierig
und wenn du dir feminist Außenpolitik
auf die Fahnen geschrieben hast und dann
gehen dort tausende zehntausende
hunderttausende Frauen auf die Straße
und ich habe diese Videos gesehen mal
das musst du dich mal trauen ne da redet
einer von diesen von diesen
Sittenwächtern revolutionswächtern
stellt sich vor eine Schulklasse von 14
15 16-Jährigen und die schreien den an
und machen den fertig bis er den Raum
verlässt das musst du dich trauen oder
diese Videos ja oder diese dieses
hochbeeindrucken genau oder Frauen die
die auch das irre zu sehen die
schleichen sich von hinten ran und
ziehen irgendeinem dieser dieser
religiösen Anführer Fanatiker wie auch
immer einfach den Turban vom Kopf ja
dutzendfach hundertfach passiert dieser
Tage das musst du dich trauen und uns
fällt nichts ein als uns gegenseitig zu
versichern dass wir die ich finde die
also
unverhältnismäßige Gewalt
das heißt gewisse Gewalt von
Sicherheitskräften ist okay aber das
jetzt unfähig unverhältnis ein bisschen
zu viel also nicht übertreiben wenn ich
schwierig finde ich wirklich schwierig
das ist nicht nur schwierig oder
schwierig ist wie unverhältnismäßige
Gewalt ja es ist komplett falsch ja das
ist komplett falsch und die Überlegung
die dahinter ist wird vermutlich
irgendwann und ich habe mit Olaf Scholz
nicht drüber geredet sein dass dieser
Konflikt
dass dieser mutiger Aufstand der Massen
ja angeführt von den Frauen gegen das
mulla-regime für uns zum falschen
Zeitpunkt kommt
Deutschland ist der wichtigste
Handelspartner des Iran und das ist
trotz aller Sanktionen nicht wenig und
wenn wir jetzt nachdem wir die harten
russland-sanktionen haben ja und
versuchen sozusagen die wirtschaftlichen
Beziehungen zu Russland einzufrieren
oder gänzlich abzubrechen das jetzt auch
noch gegenüber dem Iran tun würden dann
würde die eine oder andere Krise noch
größer als sie jetzt schon ist und ich
glaube dass solche pragmatischen Gründe
ja einfach ausreichen dass man sich hier
nicht zu weit aus dem Fenster lehnt
Lippenbekenntnisse was heißt das wenn
stolz sagt wir stehen an der Seite des
Volkes oder was weiß ich was wo sind wir
denn da im Alltag präsent
das ist ja tatsächlich ist das ja alles
was wir da bisher gemacht haben im
Grunde genommen egal ob das von Werbung
kommt oder ob das von Scholz kommt ja
das ist im Grunde genommen ist das nur
schönheitskosmetik das sind gut meinen
the Worte genau die am Ende nichts
kosten weil wir uns in der gegenwärtigen
Lage es wird dem Iran nicht endgültig
verderben wollen und weißt du was auch
im Hintergrund steht wir haben ja schon
so viel drüber gesprochen über die
Verschiebung der politischen Tektonik
und die wahrscheinlich gibt es die
Befürchtung dass wenn wir jetzt den Iran
stärker sanktionieren und wenn das in
einer Situation passiert wo am Ende doch
die Revolution scheitern sollte und wir
nach wie vor aber noch versuchen müssen
mit dem Iran irgendwie mit dem jetzigen
Müller Iran klarzukommen wir Angst haben
dass die vollends auf die russische
Seite wechseln die sie hier
offensichtlich schon mit Drohnen
beliefern und vielen anderen mehr und
ich glaube dass all diese diplomatischen
Dinge am Ende wichtiger sind als dieser
heldenhafte mutige Widerstand der jungen
Frauen
ihre Unterdrücker das ist leider meine
Befürchtung und dabei finde ich haben
wir als Deutschland ich meine wenn man
mal ein ganz kleiner askurs in die
Geschichte ne ich finde wir haben da
eine besondere Verantwortung was denn
Iran angeht ich meine ab den 50er Jahren
ja war die Bundesrepublik war im Grunde
der wichtigste Handelspartner des Irans
und wir haben ganz viel von diesem
Handel hat die Bundesregierung mit
Bürgschaften gefördert wir waren ab den
60er Jahren der wichtigste
Waffenexporteur für für den Iran wir
haben dorthin waffenexportiert in einem
gigantischen Ausmaß ja
wir haben dafür gesorgt dass Iraner zum
Studium in die Bundesrepublik gekommen
ganz ganz großen Stil wir haben auch
übrigens interessant weil wir über jeden
Fall vor allen Dingen
aber noch mehr Maschinenbau Maschinenbau
wir haben aber auch zum Beispiel
den Aufbau von
Atomkraftwerken im Iran mit befördert
gegen die möglichen Bedenken der
Amerikaner das waren wir wir waren da
immer ganz vorne mit dabei übrigens das
alles zu Zeiten in denen der Iran auch
keine wunderbare Demokratie war sondern
zur Zeit in der scharherrschaft so wo es
ebenfalls eine gefürchtete Geheimpolizei
gab das hat ja eine lange Tradition
Folterkeller das Ganze also das ist ja
alles nicht neu ja wenn man sich an die
berühmte
schardemo erinnert 1967 also da wo Benno
ohne sorgt damals gestorben ist genau ja
dann war das damals schon der Protest
der Studenten dass Deutschland sich mit
einem solchen widerlichen Autokraten
einlässt genau 67 ne war das da hat
damals Karl-heinz kuraz hat bene ohne
Sorge erschossen
gearbeitet hat genau was vermutlich
nicht der Grund war warum er geschossen
hat das konnte man dann nachher nicht
mehr erzählen ja genau aber das dann
natürlich die die Studentenbewegung in
zum Thema berühmte Bilder ja
absolut und das war ja jemand der war ja
nur aus Schaulust da war ja gar kein
Demonstrant der war ja nur weil da was
los war da hingegangen und seine
Freundin beugt sich dann über den Toten
Benno ohne sorgt
und er Regierende Bürgermeister geht mit
dem Schar in die Zauberflöte
da hat man im Nachhinein natürlich auch
gesagt wie konnte man denn mit jemandem
wie dem Schar und so weiter man konnte
immer man konnte mit jemand wie und man
kann auch mit jemand wie ramene ja also
die deutschen wenn es um ihre
Wirtschaftsbeziehungen ging und so
weiter war der Iran immer ein sehr sehr
bevorzugt bis zum Jahr der Revolution
1979 ne war der Iran der größte
Öllieferant der Bundesrepublik so und
umgekehrt war der Iran einer der
wichtigsten Absatzmärkte für uns ja in
in der sogenannten Dritten Welt und was
also interessanter Fakt zu der ja
eigentlich de facto nicht gehört ne das
muss man sagen aber interessant also
dieses zwei Sachen dazu ich habe mal mit
Fahrrad Diba der letzten Frau des Schahs
ein Interview gemacht hier in Hamburg
die liegt mittlerweile in Paris
und ich habe sie damals darauf
angesprochen auf diese Unruhen in Berlin
wie sieht das erlebt hat und den Tod von
von Benno ohne Sorg und so weiter und
ich bin bis heute erstaunt darüber wie
wenig die das damals begriffen haben die
gar nicht überhaupt nicht ja die Fahrt
ist ein sehr nette Frau ja wirklich tut
keiner Fliege was zu Leide und so weiter
sehr anständig sehr nett und überhaupt
nicht irgendwie ja da kommt jetzt
irgendwie
die ehemalige
wie nennen wir sie Kaiserin
weibliche Form von Schaar
die Frau des scharf auf jeden Fall
gar nichts ist jemand der ganz mit
beiden Beinen auf dem Boden steht aber
überhaupt kein Problem Bewusstsein dafür
und überhaupt kein Problem Bewusstsein
dafür was was dort dieses Regime damals
war die die Taten das alles ja der Schar
und auch sie und alles was da dran hängt
in Bewusstsein dass sie eigentlich das
beste für das Land wollen und was
wirklich interessant ist ist wir haben
noch während der Unruhen 78 ne hat der
Schar 6 U-Boote und vier Fregatten in
Deutschland bestellt 78 und das hat die
deutsche Bundesregierung damals
unterstützt und eben auch die die
Förderung ja den Bau von zwei deutschen
Atomkraftwerken
Meran obwohl die Amerikaner gesagt haben
lass mal stecken also ich will nur sagen
wir haben als deutsche da eine besondere
Verantwortung und deswegen finde ich
auch diese Reaktion so unfassbar lauwarm
und denke was ist das eigentlich der
wird der Westen spielt leider leider
eine nicht besonders heilsame Rolle was
die politische Geschichte des Iran
anbelangt das geht noch sehr viel weiter
also das war ja so dass am Anfang die
Engländer ganz groß in Ölgeschäft waren
im Iran und irgendwann kam im Iran ein
progestiver sympathischer Reformen an
die Macht ja mit musterdeck man muss ja
sehen die arabischen Länder hatten ja
alle mal solche Bewegungen genau ja mal
gucken oder oder die Türkei hatte mit
Kemal Atatürk ja später die Ägypter mit
nasser so diesen Versuch der vor
westlichung
westoxification ne so haben die das
damals interessant also sind die Angst
westlich verwässlich zu werden eine
einer und das hat auch natürlich zu tun
mit diesem Wahnsinns Lifestyle den diese
scharfamilie auch gepflegt hat änderst
du dich hier meine wir sind ja in dem
Alter dieser berühmte Pfauenthron ja die
Jüngeren die uns zuhören kennenlernen
wahrscheinlich auf dem faulen Thron
genau dass er auch noch gut aussehender
Mann und das passt dann natürlich alles
zusammen und den deutschen Medien
Boulevard mit den Ball dieser Pfauen
Thron dass das war ein auch das ein
Ikonographie auch diese ganzen
Geschichten um Soraya und faradiva Alter
das war ein große yellopress-geschichten
ja die schönen persischen
morgenländischen Prinzessinnen ja wo
dann die die Ex Kaiserin gegen die Sex
Kaiserin ausgewechselt wurde weil sie
keine Kinder kriegen konnte und so das
waren damals sozusagen die großen
boulevardisten Themen aber was ich sagen
wollte die hatten unter mossa Deck
damals ein ein gewählten Regierungschef
der die öleindustrie verstaatlichen
wollte und der ansonsten diese ganzen
Liberalen wie wir heute sagen westlichen
Reformen durchführen wollten und der ist
damals von den Engländern und von den
Amerikanern gestürzt worden und der
Schah ist inthronisiert worden
weil die damals ihre Gründe
haben wir von schwimmen lassen wollen
und auch cumini ist mit Unterstützung
des Westens an die Macht gekommen das
darf man nicht vergessen also nachdem
klar war dass der Schar nicht mehr zu
halten ist
hatte man wieder Angst die Muster der
Leute kommen dran ja oder noch schlimmer
Kommunisten und sowas war ja noch Zeit
des Kalten Krieges und so haben wir eine
durchaus unheilvolle Deutschland eine
geringere aber insgesamt der Westen
keine gute Rolle in dieser Geschichte
gespielt die heißt Haltung und Befreiung
des Iran anbelangt
das ist das ist halt der Punkt und das
ist auch glaube ich das was was die
Leute so frustriert und was sie am Ende
ja auch dazu geführt hat dass das dieses
mularegime jetzt seit so langer Zeit
sich dort an der Macht hätte ich meine
man fragt sich doch aus heutiger
Perspektive fragt man sich wie konnte
man eigentlich auf die Wahnsinnsidee
kommen diesen Leuten zuzujubeln den
Boden zubereiten aber wenn du das mal
hörst wenn du den Hintergrund verstehst
wenn du merkst dass es in Wahrheit immer
nur um Rohstoffe gegen es gegen Öl und
Öl und nochmals Öl und wir haben alles
dafür getan um diese diese Ölquellen im
Iran zu sichern die Amerikaner aber auch
wir Deutschen und und haben zugesehen
wie Leute in Folterkellern verschwunden
sind haben zugesehen wie das Land
ausgeplündert wurde haben zugelassen
dass von diesem immensen Reichtum der da
entstand bist du siehst darüber die
Parallelen zu Russland ne wenn man sich
mal anschaut von diesem immensen
Reichtum bei den einfach immer derselbe
nicht angegeben mehr Bodenschätze ein
Land hat wahrscheinlicher ist es dass es
von Autokraten regiert wird wie viele
ölländer bedeuten eine ölländer kennst
du die lupenreine Demokratien sind
und das und das war's ja und überall da
wo es solche begehrten Bodenschätze gibt
mit Autokraten kann man immer am Ende
besser Geschäfte machen und es ist ja
auch so ich denke mir immer wenn es dem
Iran endlich gelingen sollte sich zu
befreien was passiert dann mit diesem
Land dieses Land würde ja dann
irgendwann einen großen wirtschaftlichen
Boom kriegen das wird ja jetzt
ausgesaugt ja von Leuten die in der
Schweiz ihre Konten haben und so weiter
ja und und Milliarden aus diesem Land
rausziehen ich meine das eine der
größten Ölproduzenten der Welt ja und
den Menschen geht es von Jahr zu Jahr
schlechter wenn das anständig verteilt
würde untereinander wenn das richtig gut
funktionierendes Land würde dann würde
der Iran gewaltig erblühen aber das
gewaltige erblühen ist das Landes würde
auch die Bedeutung des Iran weiter
stärken und dann haben wir dieses ganz
schwierige
internationale Gemengelage die Rivalität
mit Saudi-Arabien und so weiter das
heißt also ich weiß nicht wen es nicht
alles gibt ja der am Ende dieses Muller
Regime auch noch unterstützt um die
jetztige quasi Stabilität die ja keine
echte ist aber sozusagen das jetztige
Gleichgewicht oder die jetzige
Konstellation zu fördern ich will da gar
nicht hinter die Kulissen gucken also
ich kann mir nicht vor die mullas können
sich doch nur an der Macht halten weil
sie auch irgendwo unterstützt und
gefördert werden und weil es irgendwie
Leute gibt die ihn Interesse daran haben
dass sie an der Macht sind
ja sowas was ich was diese unheilvollen
Allianzen die sich da bilden die siehst
du ja ich meine in der Ukraine kommen
iranische Kamikaze Drohnen und zwar
ganze Schwärme zum Einbau nicht da so
viele davon haben dass sie ja die
abgegeben können die Kosten nix die sind
unglaublich billig die sind auch nicht
präzise das ist aber egal weil es die
schiere Menge ist die einfach Angst
sozusagen die Schrotflinte am Himmel
genau Angst und Terror verbreitet und
wenn du diese Bilder siehst wie wie arme
ukrainische Polizisten versuchen mit
Hilfe einer Pistole diese Dinger aus der
Luft zu schießen damit sie am Himmel
explodieren und nicht irgendwo am Boden
und wieder irgendjemanden umbringen der
gerade zufällig auf dem Weg zur Schule
ist ja dass das ist wirklich gruselig
aber die ich glaube die die Geschichte
dahinter und da glaube ich schon ich
wäre immer extrem zuversichtlich dass
aus dieser Situation jetzt etwas
Großartiges erwachsen kann weil
Iraner sind sehr gut ausgebildet auch
viele Frauen Mittler sehr viel mehr
Frauen als Männer genau die an den Unis
sind und so weiter also zwei Drittel
aller Studierenden in im Iran sind
Frauen so genau denkt ja sogar
inzwischen im iranischen über eine
Männerquote nach wirklich ja ja es gibt
tatsächlich mehrere politische
Bestrebungen in die Richtung und in
einem Punkt sogar noch aus einer
gewissen nachvollziehbaren Logik also
was am allerhöchsten eben ansehen steht
im Iran ist der Medizinstudium nicht
zuletzt daran zu erkennen wie viel
iranische Ärzte es in Deutschland gibt
aber der größte Stolz der Familie bist
du wenn du Mediziner wirst das ist in
Deutschland ähnlich aber es im Iran noch
sehr viel stärker
und nun ist es so dass mittlerweile
immer mehr frauenmedizin studieren und
immer weniger Männer
das ist auch kein Problem wenn man als
Arzt als Ärztin dann in Teheran
praktiziert das ist aber ein Problem in
den ländlichen Regionen wo die Männer
keine Frauen als Ärztinnen akzeptieren
das heißt also du hast jetzt hier auch
noch Interesse rückständigkeiten im
bestimmten Bereichen dass man sagt wir
haben zu wenig Ärzte Betonung nicht auf
männlich
aber es ist natürlich auch interessant
was ist mit einer patriarchanischen
Gesellschaft los in der es vor allen
Dingen für Frauen interessant ist höhere
Bildungsgrade zu erreichen und für
Männer meistens nicht das ist ja auch
eine merkwürdige Geschichte und auf der
anderen Seite ist es natürlich auch
grandioses Zeichen dass in einem
islamistischen Land so viele Frauen
studieren und studieren können ja
wir erzählen das immer wieder Iraner die
sagen fahr nach Teheran schaust die an
Dich ich hätte das so gerne mal
geschafft aber es hat aus diversen
Gründen nie geklappt man sagt ihm was
auf was dort wirklich läuft hat mit dem
westlichen Klischee sozusagen einer
völlig Unterdrückten und freudlosen
Gesellschaft nicht viel zu tun wir haben
unsere Wege gefunden was hinter
verschlossen
passiert ist müssen zwei parallele
Welten sein genau und Monika Fabricius
Kollegen hier aus unserer Redaktion
liebe Grüße die uns auch häufig hilft in
der Vorbereitung auch das Podcasts und
so weiter und dann eine sehr kluge weit
gereizte Frau berichtete dass sie
überrascht davon war dies durch durch
den Iran gereist wie viele Frauen so wie
zufällig im Auto und dann anderen
Stellen dann einfach sagen ja die die
Kopfbedeckung so runterfallen lassen wie
zufällig fällt das Ding runter wie
zufällig sind die Haare nicht richtig
bedeckt und sie sagte zu ihrer großen
Überraschung hat sie in der Türkei als
sie durch die Türkei gereist ist
festgestellt das wird dort sehr viel
akkurater gehandhabt als im Iran es
würde man niemals denken was zeigt dass
da unter diesen Schleiern echt was los
ist und was brodelt und ich glaube nur
dass es aber im Hintergrund einen
Wettlauf gibt der gefährlich ist ja der
Wettlauf nämlich um die Bombe ja in die
Frage ist was kommt zuerst also schaffen
die es wirklich ernsthaft an die Bombe
zu kommen und es gibt ernst nehmen die
Leute die sagen seit Mai sind sie
eigentlich schon soweit und das geht
jetzt sozusagen exponentiell nach oben
die haben in Wahrheit schon die
Möglichkeit
Atom bestückte Raketen irgendwo
hinzuschicken oder werden sie vorher
gestürzt weil jetzt diese Proteste sich
einfach immer ausweiten und sich dieses
Regime nicht halten kann das ist glaube
ich der Wettlauf um den es geht und da
geht es jetzt keine Zeit zu verlieren
darauf will ich hinaus und ich lauwarm
zu sagen ja natürlich wir müssen Euch
mal ein bisschen unterstützen und wie
wir sind bei euch
genau kostet nichts ja oder die
Geheimpolizei aufzufordern
verhältnismäßig zu sein in einem Land in
dem Menschen in der Nacht verschwinden
und nie wiederkommen oder von der
Geheimpolizei tot wo die Haustür gelegt
werden und mit der Aufforderung jemand
so schnell wie möglich auch zu beerdigen
wo Leichen geklaut werden damit man
nicht mehr feststellen kann was da
eigentlich Identitäten vernichtet also
es ist das ist alles ganz gruselig und
grauenhaft jetzt könnte man positiv
sagen
es gibt den berühmten Talk will-effekt
und Alexi Detox will von dem ich
häufiger mal erzähle waren cooler Mann
war bis du bist Fan ja ja kein
uneingeschränkter Fan aber zumindest
weil ausgesprochen kluger Mensch Adliger
Anfang des 19 Jahrhunderts und der Talk
wille-effekt ist beschäftigt sich mit
der Frage wann brechen Systeme zusammen
und er sagt Systeme die noch an sich
selber glauben brechen nie zusammen
sondern es brechen immer Systeme
zusammen die aus Angst um ihren
Fortbestand bereit sind Reformen zu
machen das ist hochinteressant also
Russland Russland bricht zusammen der
Kommunismus bricht zusammen als
Gorbatschow kommt
ja also in dich nicht nicht in der Zeit
als das starre unterspülte System ja
zumindestens noch den Anschein erweckt
an sich selbst zu glauben sondern in dem
Moment wo man sagt naja gut das alte
geht jetzt nicht mehr weiter und dann
rutscht plötzlich der ganze Prozess Weg
so ist das ja unter Gorbatschow gekommen
Gorbatschow wollte den reformierten
Kommunismus und kurz darauf war der
verlangt das ganze dann im Chaos und
dann kam capitalismus und jel ziehen und
so und der Punkt ist dass ich glaube
dass in Iran wo die Voraussetzungen für
das Wegspülen so groß ist der trotz der
Starrsinn des Regimes umso härter wird
und deswegen auch eben dieses
unglaublich brutale Vorgehen das
interessant dass du das erzählst weil
wenn man auch mit mit golinärteil zum
Beispiel spricht dann sagt eben genau
das bieten die gerade an unter anderem
auch der der
Justizminister glaube ich oder
Innenminister der vor wenigen Tagen
gesagt hat lasst uns mal reden wir
können ja verhandeln über das eine oder
andere also das wäre eigentlich ein
Signal in genau diese Richtung und ich
ich weiß nicht also ich war damals noch
zum Schluss ganz kurz erwähnt Richard
ich war zehn Jahre alt du noch ein paar
Tage älter als am ersten Februar 79
diese Sondermaschine der Air France in D
heran gelandet als diese Maschine
erinnern ich auch diese Bilder auch da
wieder ikonographisch kein Alkohol
durfte an Bord dieser Maschine serviert
werden und an Bord dieser Eier toller
die komeni ja der nach 15 Jahren
aussieht aus dem märchenbuchner für
meine Vorstellung war der es gab so
einen ein Cover von so einem
karl-may-buch was ich hatte im Lande des
macht die also das Magie ja und so sah
der aus also sah aus wie eine Figur aus
einem anderen Jahrhundert genau und und
dann kommt dieser Mann begleitet von
Journalisten aus der ganzen Welt mit an
Bord über ganz der legendäre Peter
Scholler Tour ja und der
spiegelkorrespondent Volk hat Windfuhr
glaube ich so hieß der
die waren damit an Bord und und Scholl
Natur hat er auch im Vorfeld in Paris
der war ja lange im Irak im Exil hat von
dort seine Schriften verbreitet aber
dann vor allen Dingen in den letzten
drei Monaten die er dann in Paris
verbracht hat du meinte
so wie schon Natur nein nein nein
richtig
Weltöffentlichkeit und Aufmerksamkeit
bekommen und ich ich weiß es gab Bilder
an Situationen das hat mir schon Natur
auch mal erzählt er sagte wenn der
spazieren gehen morgens in Paris dann
warteten zum Teil 400 Journalisten um zu
fotografieren wie komme ich spazieren
geht und der hat das ganz eiskalt
genutzt also die französische
Pressefreiheit die Möglichkeit
ins Land zu bringen und trotto
verbreiten der Westen ja auf kommenie
gesetzt genau nicht weil die den jetzt
Kreuz sympathisch fanden aber a haben
sie ihn unterschätzt sie haben gedacht
mit dem kommt man ins Geschäft
und das zweite war man hatte Angst es
war klar der Schar überlebt das nicht ja
wer kommt dann dran und da schien ihnen
in der damaligen Perspektive rumäni der
verlässlichere Partner zu sein genau und
diese diese Geschichte damals dieser
Krimi also diese Maschine fliegt los
keiner weiß genau wird die abgeschossen
im Anflug auf die heran dann gab es
irgendein Problem noch mit der mit der
Mitte mit mit mit den Triebwerken und
man dachte okay jetzt Attentat Anschlag
aber dann sind sie tatsächlich gelandet
und was dann passiert ist darauf wollte
ich nur zum Schluss noch kurz hinaus
die landen und dann wird dieser Mann
empfangen von Millionen von Menschen und
das Bild das ich für mich damals so
eingeprägt hat sind genau diese dunkel
gekleideten verschleierten Hijab
tragenden Frauen ja die auch da wieder
ikonographisch da war sofort klar da
passiert jetzt etwas an den der der
größten Versammlungen die es jeder
Geschichte der Menschheit gegeben hat
damals an diesem Februar Tag und in den
Wochen danach auch in Teheran und da
passiert jetzt etwas und man hatte das
Gefühl da geht jetzt ein ganzes Land
quasi freiwillig weil sie das Schahs so
überdrüssig sind und dieser Ausbeutung
ja durch die Ölfirmen und so weiter geht
jetzt freiwillig quasi zurück in die
Steinzeit und und der krasse Kontrast
ist damals diese Frauen alle mit dem
Schleier auf dem Kopf ja und jetzt
dieselben Frauen oder die gleichen
Frauen immer so will die sich den
Schleier vom Kopf reißen und ich denke
und genau da sollte man genau hingucken
weil das ist die interessante Geschichte
und ich habe das Gefühl da könnt ihr
wieder was Großes passieren also es wäre
sehr sehr zu wünschen dass was Großes
passiert was mich interessiert ist die
verschleierten Frauen von damals
die wo man sagen muss den Frauen ging es
ja unterm Schar im Vergleich zu dem was
danach passierte im Schnitt sehr viel
besser was haben die sich damals von
Community versprochen
unter den verschleierten Frauen war ja
damals auch Shirin evadi die später den
Friedensnobelpreis bekommen hat und die
dann gesagt hat ja wir haben uns
getäuscht und so weiter und die ja dann
als mutige Kämpferin für die Rechte der
Frauen und für Demokratie im Iran
aufgetreten ist und da interessiert mich
natürlich nach wie vor die Frage welche
Hoffnungen haben die Frauen damals
ausgerechnet in kumini gesetzt
weißt du was ich glaube Richard ich
glaube die kluge Antwort darauf hat auch
mal wieder golinäratei gegeben die mir
erklärt hat weißt du es geht hier nicht
nur um Mut und um sozusagen was
aufmüpfig ist ja und die wir lassen uns
das nicht mehr gefallen und die Frage
oder der große Ruf der Freiheit nicht
nur sie sagte viele viele Menschen und
die meisten Iranerinnen und Iraner sind
einfach nur verzweifelt unfassbar
verzweifelt und ich glaube das waren sie
damals auch einfach verzweifelt und
deswegen macht kaputt was dich so
verzweifelt macht und alles andere wird
sich dann irgendwie finden ich glaube
das war die Hoffnung ne so müssen wir ja
eigentlich eine doppelte Hoffnung haben
die eine Hoffnung ist dass das
molaregime tatsächlich gestürzt werden
kann
und die zweite ist dass das
unglückselige iranische Volk nicht
wieder vom Regen in Jauche kommt wie
beim letzten Mal richtig tatsächlich die
Kräfte auf die wir setzen und auf die
wir hoffen und vor allen Dingen viel
wichtiger all die Menschen im Iran
hoffen ja das ist das ist ein ein
Liberalen freiheitlichen Staat gibt im
Iran dass die sich durchsetzen in dieser
Situation
es gibt ein total schönen Gedanken oder
mehrere schöne Gedanken von
Hamed Ismail Leon ich spreche bestimmt
falsch aus aber iranischer
Schriftsteller der in Berlin lebt hat in
Berlin dieser Tage eine bewegende Rede
gehalten und zum Abschluss nur zwei
Sätze darauf in unseren Träumen feuert
niemand mehr Tränengas in die
Klassenräume der Mädchen stößt niemand
Kinder vom Dach oder schlägt ihre Köpfe
gegen Bordsteine und niemand wird mit
einer Pistole auf ihren Hinterkopf
Zielen in unseren Träumen wird endlich
der Wind der Freiheit durch die Haare
der Frauen Wehen was für ein schöner
Satz schöner kann man es nicht sagen
Richard ich danke Dir sehr
dass wir mal wieder reden konnten und so
soll es weitergehen schön dass du wieder
eine Stimme hast danke dir eine gute
Woche vielen Dank auch tschüss Markus
[Musik]
eine Produktion von m hoch 2 und Pot
Stars bei OMR im Auftrag des ZDF